I don't know go make out with every
stray boy I ever had ever had a crush on
is that weird that all I would do is
just be like a [ __ ] like be a hoe yeah
if I was a cry be ho so if I was a woman
for a day obviously the first thing I
would do we play with my boobs I feel
like it's doing that for a good 30
minutes I probably just lock myself
inside all day it's so dangerous outside
for a woman I'd probably like go mess
with dudes a lot and then I would
probably end up seeing how many things I
can get for free I'd probably try to
hook up with somebody and see what it's
like to have sex with a vagina probably
go through like go the whole day with
the vibrator inside make something that
probably feels that good wouldn't get
old so and I just do it the whole day by
some cute dresses by some cute shoes I
probably take advantage of the sale
sections and clothing stores I end the
night by going to a bar and seeing what
women have to deal with on a daily base
everything feels like it could be a
possible threat I would be curious to
see what that's like to just like walk
down a street and like have heads turn
and [ __ ] screen things that may
cause so much anxiety that if I only had
to do it for a day I think I could just
lock myself in a room and be like okay
I'm just gonna ride this out watching
Netflix if I was like a woman like full
time and like I had to go outside
because I wasn't just gonna be a day
like you really have to like become okay
with sort of how dangerous the world is
for you boy what size boobs what I want
nothing extreme I don't want it to be a
distraction which is interesting that
guys don't don't think about that right
it's not like oh I just want like I
don't want to dick that's like a
distraction hey every guy's just like oh
the biggest [ __ ] dick